if ariana turns the stove dial 135
degrees to the right what setting will
the dial be on
so two very important things up here
first she's turning the dial 135 degrees
and which way is she turning the dial
she's turning the dial
to the right
so here's our dial it's facing up
this red dial right here facing up sort
of like on a clock
and we're going to be turning the dial
to the right
and how far to the right
135 degrees so this dial will turn until
it's reached 135 degrees
so how can we figure out if we start
turning this dial when to stop when it's
reached 135 degrees
well one common way would be to use a
protractor we could set up our
protractor measure out 135 degrees
but in this case we can't do that
because we don't have a protractor so
let's use some other information some
other stuff we know about angles to see
if we can solve this
one thing i know one angle
that we see a lot is a 90 degree angle
and a 90 degree angle if we start up at
the top like our dial
and turn
90 degrees
we're going to end up with an angle like
this
an angle where we can put a square in
the middle and finish the square it
looks like a square angle so this is a
90 degree angle
so coming over to our dial if we start
at the top and we go 90 degrees
so we start here at the top and we go 90
degrees
we'd end up on the low setting
90 degrees
but we're not going 90 we're going 135
which is more than 90 degrees so here's
one clue we know we're going farther
than the low setting we don't know how
much farther we're definitely going to
go past the low setting
another angle i could use to help me
is a straight angle
180 degrees
if 180 degree angle again starts at the
top like our knob is currently like our
dial
it will go all the way around until we
have a straight angle
like
this so again looking at our knob if we
started at the top and we went around
180 degrees
we would end up facing straight down
at medium
this would be
180. degrees
so where does 135 fall well 135 falls
somewhere in between 90 and 180.
was not far enough of a turn and 180 was
too far of a turn
so we want something in the middle and
what setting is in the middle of the 90
and the 180
right here in the middle of them is
medium
low
so turning our stove dial 135 degrees to
the right
we'll set our stove to medium
low you